[Music]
thank you so much my name is Brianna and
I'm a former pageant girl I'm Rebecca
marker and I'm a pageant girl hi I'm
Jerri and I've competed in one pageant
my name is Emily and I'm a former
pageant girl
the only people would ask is there a
height requirement how expensive it is
just really expensive our pageant girls
mean or like the weird stuff like
flippers and butt glue
for the most part it is something to do
with community service Piazza pesum
academic achievement your beauty
sometimes swimsuit the way that you can
present yourself answered questions like
what would I do to save the world and
stuff like that oh that's a tough one I
don't think that patterns are intended
to be sexist I think that intended to be
empowering and to show that beauty is
not just about physical beauty but also
you are on a stage and you are sometimes
being objectified if you look this way
in a swimsuit and the other girl doesn't
then unfortunately you are more likely
to win just based on your looks
I think pageants may be a little bit
sexist in that they only recognize a
very narrow view of beauty but I don't
think there's anything wrong with the
women that do do pageants and recognize
for themselves that they are beautiful
and that's okay to show the ones that
I've competed in have been mostly about
my community service and about my
education not about the way that I look
I think beauty pageants boost
self-confidence if you win and if you
don't win then you'll be comparing
yourself to the person who did it is a
little bit hard to be surrounded by
gorgeous women and not feel like there
might be something wrong with your face
I'm fine now I came into beauty pageants
after being bullied and it really helped
me grow my confidence back and believe
in myself again I always got first
runner-up so I don't know if I can
answer that correctly I guess you just
have to impress the panel of judges on
pretty much every single category it's
all about your package and who you are
and what you're selling the judges I
would say 80% of a beauty pageant is
what you're wearing your walk your hair
your makeup and the other 20% is your
answers to the questions that they ask
you they can be beneficial depending on
why you enter if you are entering to
gain self-confidence or because you like
to you know dress up and have fun then
it can be beneficial to you but not if
you're the kind of person who will
really have the self esteem hit if they
don't win I want a lot of
self-confidence after winning that
pageant and also I want a scholarship
pageants taught me how to do a really
mean catwalk so they can benefit you Oh
pageant walk has a lot of confidence you
have to strut your stuff you have to be
elegant and poised and just look really
graceful you are always supposed to be
facing the judges and the audience just
walk with confidence you're walking very
balanced and you have your shoulders
back and your chest high
and just remember to relax your arms so
you don't want like t-rex arms remember
to make eye contact with the judges show
them that you're confident and like
super cute